me and Gary be up in the office you wrap
that bit will fit through corporation
talks about ownership and leverage 1800
sexes out there benefit so I think you
need like I do I think we need everyone
to have very lasers oh but if it were
already exam me you know when there's a
function it's that I like a lot that I
like a lot
all right thank you good start
[Music]
hi how are you
Kelsey real pleasure I'll be right with
nowhere you need a few minutes I finally
feel like I'm truly in the right place
and time where I should be
professionally and like this is where it
be and I truly feel this company like
literally you're gonna send me an email
I'm gonna ask you to send me an email
which I'm gonna use this mic to do list
and it's literally going to be you know
I'm literally gonna go get all your
feedback like speak to Claud speak to
Steve speak to Jason and see if there's
something I can help you with I'm not
sore I'm cramping in the middle of my
back which is not allowing me to
function would love to just get ass all
aligned on what our strategy is and and
see what we can get done so what has
happened since we last met
I apologize one minute this is give you
an update on the team also to kind of
like start having a high-level
discussion on just like going in the
shore State of the Union yeah what do we
want to be doing in parallel is an
industry that is going to be massive and
will continue nothing's changed for my
level of my belief and you know it's
interesting I was in Hong Kong
they're called ko Elle's they're key
opinion leaders the Kol market in China
and Asia is out of control
because because the platform's owned
everything and because everything is tip
based so like like all the key
influencers are getting like tips and
while they live chat like I really want
you deeply focused on this because I
know what's gonna happen that I know I'm
right about in the same way that I knew
I was right about social media ads I
believe that vaynermedia wins too
obnoxious media AORs on the back of our
disproportionate
truth that we understand influencer
marketing better and I believe that we
can make the market fully believe that
in 2022 and that's smart
cool thank you such a pleasure I'll be
right with you the way to really win is
to have a pillar write book is a pillar
but it's a historic pillar to me a
new-age pillar is either a vlog or a
podcast and you should have one or the
other
period like to me ironically actually
the first time I'm saying this to me
ironically if you do not have a vlog or
a podcast right now you're just leaving
an enormous amount of opportunity to me
you know I guess I'm hedging but like to
me it's you become vulnerable to not
being to not being relevant like you
need to have both of them one of them or
do you need to be an actual celebrity
like to me it's the only thing that
equals having a television show or being
an actor or actress or like it's a
pillar that's that's why you're
struggling okay you've you put quality
some your personal subjective quality on
a pedestal it is such a cliche reason
people struggle okay you're gonna have
to jump into the pool and just see what
happens in the same way at a macro level
writing the book itself you've got to
basically do the same thing with social
okay there's no piece of content with
bad enough lighting with with bad enough
quality with like there's no piece of
content that's gonna take you down it's
such a pleasure have a great day
sure of course
[Music]
hi I feel like there's a lot of exciting
things hawking it now and I feel like I
want to make sure that I'd be smart
about short-term helping the company
long term working towards my goal good
for you you know I'm turning 30 and what
we gonna have and that just you know
stress a lot of thoughts and feelings
100% I'm so acutely aware the next
couple years can make a huge difference
yeah that's probably right I would tell
you a couple things as somebody who's 41
that is right and shockingly always
right like there are so many people that
are 57 years old right now have
misplayed it in their own mind and other
people's minds for the last you know 37
years and legitimate can make a decision
tomorrow that makes the next 30 years of
their life so fruitful that it covers
the warts of the prior 40 I genuinely
know that to be true so you're right but
I think it's imperative that you don't
[ __ ] yourself that there's this
magical 36 month window between 30 and
33 that if you play it right you go on
to have this incredible life and if you
don't you have a fraction of it there's
absolute truth to that there's also
equal non truth to it if you decide to
make a decision at 33
instead of tripling down on the right
career decisions I would argue that one
of the best things you can do for you to
really win is developing an off-speed
pitch to your normal demeanor that
allows you to have it's unbelievable how
much comfort I have in I'm content
while still hungrier than anything I've
ever even seen that's [ __ ] balanced I
realize that I never even knew your
middle name I realize that summer's over
it was my time to go
Paul sit in front of my piano how's the
draft and if L trap I'm not used to
think you like growing up he did my
dream was to be a John matter than your
judge my dream was to be the first GM
since 69
[Music]
[Music]
hello gang how are you how are things I
used to sell lemonade as you guys
probably know and one time a guy in a
bike I will never forget the story stop
sin has like a classic old-school 1980s
water bottle so just a plastic water
bottle and he goes fill this up and I'll
give you $10 and it was probably a
dollar 25 worth of lemonade if you
measured it I don't think he even got to
fill this up and I'll give you I think
he said by the time he was done with up
I had it fully filled up and that $10 to
this day I've never had a transaction
million multi-million dollar
transactions never felt like that to
this day so I get that $34 day I have
one it's a $10 fill up and it feels
better than anything I've ever done but
professionally and so how's it going
right now with okay
so that's the big punch line like you
feel from afar that you like are
intrigued by how much I care about that
and talk about that and it seems like
right - you got it all right so look
here's a couple core things number one
you can't control anything at scale the
way you control it is at a macro so
here's what I mean by that couple things
that I think will stand out number one
you have to fire people that undermine
the culture that you want with guard
--less of what they do if you end up
having 11 locations and the regional
manager because that's the way you
decide to the structure and she or he
has five stores under their watch and
their stores are doing the best
financially but you know that she's
either changed or it's been exposed that
he
can't manage the people anymore you have
to fire that person the biggest reason
people lose on culture is they value the
money the person brings to the table
over the undermining to that person's
creating to culture it's as simple as
that I think the number one way to make
culture great is to use a parenting
analogy parents that really dominate do
the following
there's a thing Ricky's going to new
high school we have to pick the high
school Sally wants to go to sleepaway
camp which one we don't like Sally's new
boyfriend Rick like all that [ __ ] right
what great parents do is they go into
the bedroom [ __ ] Duke get the [ __ ]
out and then walk out of that room
United Front and there's no veering from
the narrative I have did a great job
with that at Wine Library I did a good
job with it at Vayner and then I did a
bad job of it what I never told Steve or
the people of his level and higher was
no friction amongst us 50 and that's why
there's a lot to fix for Vayner in my
opinion because every single leader here
blindly needs to support every other
leader and then hash it out and then use
me as the supreme court because they may
not be able to get to a resolution but
then they can come to me and I make
decisions and then they have to blindly
support that or they can leave if they
hate my decision working on everything
in music right now but and I'm recording
things but I don't feel like they're as
good as they're going to be six months
from now when I'm really ready to put it
out what I still want to throw a phrase
do what it likes is I would put it out I
would put it out anyway but I would put
it out anyway under that pretext so for
example II gotta be smart with strategy
maybe you call it alpha alpha music :
and then you just put the title of the
song and people like what the [ __ ] is
alpha music like you'd literally just
like we literally just made it up it's
out the music it's now that we're in a
world of journey of documenting the
journey and I know my music is gonna get
substantially better this is music I'm
making I'd like you to hear it I want to
document my journey but I'd like to call
it alpha music because it's not ready
for primetime who says you can't
I don't know I like this one but by the
way this is why I document because I
feel like that's just a really click I
feel like that's what I would do if I
was doing it right
[Music]
you guys ready one minute good hey I'm
Joe Harris my name is Juan I'll sävar my
name is Daniel Festival I soon capital
right to start this what's in it for me
is the questions you're in a branding
speedgame give the build a brand the end
he heard me you understood it let's go
some money and let's just go one better
than I could have expected we're ready
to go he's always providing a wealth of
knowledge and giving us all these little
tidbits of advice now one thing that I
love about Gary BC he keeps it real and
he offers real solutions that you can
apply to your business immediately
making a better video that doesn't have
in the three seconds versus a worse
video that does have in 30 seconds will
most likely sell more cups of coffee or
wine I think go ahead I mean like this
is the conversation I want to have you
know what I mean why don't me more water
mark the logo of every brand in every
video why don't we put a ticker at the
bottom
why don't we invent the ticker for
videos on Facebook the way ESPN or CNBC
over where the [ __ ] invent some day some
gal or guys sat in a room like this and
said let's make a [ __ ] ticker
there was no tickers in 1972 Andy I want
to create you know how ESPN has a ticker
I want every video that I make for the
next six months to have a ticker I don't
know I now only put out videos with
tickers let everybody start designing
that was my new thing I'm now the ticker
guide
three two one respect seconds short sure
great let's go take care guys
[Music]
you
[Music]